foreign.
[Silence]
forb.
Continuing
[Silence]
in
the chapter of repentance. We're at the
very end of the chapter of repentance.
He mentions the 23rd narration. Now
there are there is one narration that we
skipped
and that narration is the narration of
Malik
and the story of his repentance.
It's a very very very long narration. If
we were to start that narration, we'd be
doing it for the next two weeks. ,
however, it is not a story that any
Muslim
should be unaware of. It's a story that
a person should read and contemplate.
It's an incredibly touching story. It's
a wonderful story. And there are many
very wonderful, touching, beautiful
narrations that are a bit lengthy that
we may skip in our journey through
simply due to the time constraint and
it would be difficult to u hold a
continuous
a continuous train of thought throughout
so many days.
however
it is the 21st narration
in the chapter of repentance. It's
collected by both Bkari and Muslim and
so it warrants
our attention. So we should read this
narration to ourselves, go through it.
, and always review these narrations
on your own. Have a copy of
review it before
at the night before. Review it after
we discuss each narration. Review it.
Look at the narration. develop some
questions in your mind. Ask the text
questions about itself and try to see
if they they are answered throughout our
explanation of the narration. If they
are unanswered, then ask inshallah.
But in order to properly and adequately
benefit,
you should always review the narrations
on your own and read them on your
own. Not just for the first time or
second, but in a constant way to keep
these companions and to keep the life
and times of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam and his words at the forefront
of your mind. We have a narration here
on the authority of Abbass andb Malik
who narrate that the messenger of Allah.
Wasam said and this is regarding the
nature of the human being. Regarding the
nature of the human being
he says sallall.aii alaihi wasallam. If
the son of Adam had a valley of gold,
he would wish that he had two of them.
In another wording of this same
narration, and if he had two, he would
wish that he had three.
[Silence]
If if the son of Adam had
a valley of gold,
he would wish that he had a second to go
with it.
And in another wording, and if he had
two, he would wish that they were three.
The only thing that will adequately fill
the mouth of the human being is dirt.
This means that a the human being
naturally
if he allows his greed, if he allows
that desire for wealth or that desire
for whatever it is he is pursuing,
if he allows it to run rampant and if he
follows that desire rather than making
that desire follow him,
this person will never be satisfied.
ified by anything short of death. That
is the only thing that will end put an
end to that greed or put an end to that
pursuit.
And so the statement here that the only
thing that will fill his mouth
adequately is dirt. meaning the dirt of
his grave when he dies
and when he passes away that is the only
thing that will put an end to that
pursuit.
This is the human being's nature.
However, this does not apply
in its entirety to the believer. This
is the human being's nature. However,
the believer fights against this nature,
cartails this nature, rectifies this
nature, remedies this nature with what?
With the Quran, with the Sunnah,
remedies this nature with alternatives
to his worldly pursuits.
And so
this is the nature of the human
being. The only thing that will put a an
end to that nagging constant desire
whipping at his back throughout his life
for more and more and more is the dirt
of his grave. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
then says
forch.
[Silence]
Buddha.
The prophet Sam
said the only thing that will adequately
fill the human being's mouth and satisfy
him is dirt and Allah will forgive those
who repent to him. Why he will forgive
those who repent to him? What does this
sentence have to do with the previous?
This sentence has to do with the
previous in the sense that if a person
allows his greed to rule him. If he
allows his impulses to drive him, if he
does not change this about himself by
force, by hook or by crook as they say,
then this person on his path to trying
to find
to trying to find that which will
satiate this hunger.
The person will step on others on the
way. The person will hurt others on the
way. The person will take what is not
his. The person will commit terrible
things on his path to pursuing
that which will satiate his greed. But
his greed will never be satiated. And it
will only get worse. And the thrill will
only have to be more potent, just a
drug. And so the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam tells us that even if a person
lives such a life and even if they only
wake up to their wrongdoing at the very
end Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
forgives those who turn to him in
repentance.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.